they will get five uh Iranians as well
yeah Jackie why we need to add $6
billion dollar on top of that to it's
his policies I mean this is just true
this is not partisan it is his policies
that got us here uh we've got a
compilation right now of Biden
Administration officials uh explaining
some of their poor policies regarding
Iran aren't going to be released for
nothing in exchange didn't they also get
five Iranians they will get five
Iranians as well yeah Jackie we need to
add6 billion dollar on top of
that this is the deal that uh we were
able to strike Biden's Ransom payment
will be immediately used to stoke
violence Bloodshed and Mayhem throughout
the Middle East putting Israel the
United States and the entire world in
very grave Peril Joe Biden just lit a
match to the Middle East uh Israel has
got to be on alert news that the deal is
moving forward is drawing criticism from
both sides of the aisle on Capitol Hill
the way to avoid having hostages taken
by Iran is to be strong firm and
Resolute and and to not use carrots in
the form of $6 billion dollar but to use
sticks in the form of threats to things
that Iran holds dear $6 billion they W
released and they're going to have chice
they're going to use it for humanitarian
Aid there's no guarantees of that so I'm
very much concerned about this so we're
looking into it keeper but I'm very
concerned it seems you know very clear
to the critics in both sides on the hill
money is fungible that's the criticism
and now president reesi has added fuel
to the fire that already existed of
criticism by saying we're going to do
anything we want with it but isn't it
true that this frees Teran up to spend
more on other nefarious goals like
supporting terrorism and boosting its
nuclear program and it's you know I I
can't predict what they'll do going
forward here as dcy explained to you
money's fungible right uh and so uh any
Financial relief uh can be used by the
regime in another way and that's why
there is um real controversy to that
money is fungible so Iran may have known
this money is coming and used other
funds to help fund this attack that
happened Iran has Iran has unfortunately
always used and focused its funds on
supporting terrorism on supporting
groups like uh like Hamas I assure you
guys we could have shown a way longer
compilation of the confusions and
outright lies and obfuscations from this
Administration related to that you can
thank me for not showing you anything
from Karen jeanpierre I love this phrase
money is fungible and that they all
start repeating it of course it is
you're not going to believe this I pay
all the guys in this room uh guys you do
whatever you want with the money right
you don't ask me when you're having
lunch or you're buying your chick
something or yeah everybody money's
fungible you give it to somebody they
can do what they want with
it